[Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  lots of special events taking place in  honor of comic-con yesterday at the san  diego library there was a Quidditch  tournament yes yes and trust me when a  bunch of adults get together and play  Quidditch there are no winners there  were people I'm sorry  there was a whole section that was so  happy Conan likes credits why we see it  right now right now they're hiding their  broom I know white Walker is another  name for a Trump cabinet member  what what superhero smells too strongly  of Cologne uberman Oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  the way touching keema playing brothers  Sam and Dean Winchester Jared Padalecki  and Jensen Apple  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  Oh lucu came crawling back well settle  in it's only two hours to San Diego